[Música]
já dizia alecsandro de mas que os laços
do casamento são tão fortes são tão
pesados que às vezes são precisas três
pessoas prospectados
eu sou psicóloga clínica e os casais são
minha paixão e no consultório acompanha
vários tipos de casais casados nunca
casados homo e entrou aos machos se há
coisa que não tem ensinado é que cada
casal é um planeta cada casal é o único
em sua atmosfera específica a sua
química suas linguagens suas narrativas
os seus gritos e sobretudo as suas
fronteiras e por vezes aliás tantas
vezes vai chegar estes planetas um os
troy
é um atleta que chega eo enfrenta
contudo em finalidades traz ao
certamente sabem do que falam
hoje estou aqui mais de mil pessoas e
alguns estudos indicam que tem
finalidades tocar cerca de 30 65 por
cento dos casais
basta fazer as contas não são números
pequenos tanto não só nos pequenos com
aquele chão uma epidemia
a epidemia em inferioridade mas será que
podemos chamar de pne ao quil sempre
existiu
seu provável é que a ex-namorada do que
o colega trabalho
aquela paixão antiga que nos visita
ainda que só em sonhos mais do que uma
epidemia em finalidade é um conjunto de
verdades desconfortáveis por dados
difíceis de inglês
eis uma dessas primeiras rodadas
desconfortáveis em fidelidade é
praticada em todas as culturas
todas as culturas são a exceção que é
também condenada em todas elas
condenado em todas elas é com desdém aos
sábados se filiava ver algo tão natural
assim para um ser humano porque
precisamos citou ameaçados com as
consequências da inferioridade vezes até
com morte e mesmo assim não conseguimos
parar de trair e mais do que isso que é
que entra nesta definição de
infertilidade é porque eu vejo casais
que têm relações abertas em que
encontrou os corpos por sete fora da
relação que o parceiro sabe tudo
tá tudo em cima da mesa todas claros não
há problema não considerou este
inferioridade e viveu muito felizes
assim sem problema
até o dia até o dia em que percebem que
afinal não tenho palavras e suas
aventuras do parceiro como achavam que
tinham e em 50 descobrem isso o
sentimento de traição é mesmo o vencedor
do avassalador com produtos usados por
exemplo a casar isso querem mais
normativas e mesmo assim é que
consideram três são basicamente tudo e
mais alguma coisa coisas banais um
jantar com amigas seja o que for
três casais com aquela busca de presos
fora do parceiro fora da relação já é
considerada uma infinidade de castro
para um jantar de amigas
mais do que isto é tudo pelo deste
contrato profissional com o casal tem no
início da canção em um contrato no final
que define a enfermidade que pode ou não
e sendo atualizado ao longo dos tempos
mas no final fiquei treinos que treme
sexo nos todos os psicopatas não
queremos saber das intenções dos outros
71 dos inconscientes que e morais que
não queremos saber das consequências das
nossas nossos atos
vamos excluir à partida desta edição é
que são as enfermidades as eleições mais
óbvios
estas ocorrem quando o casal já não
gosta quando já não estão ligados quando
já estão desconectados
em resposta relativamente banal mas não
são estes a maioria dos que acham que eu
recebo no consultório
a maioria dos casais que não chegam
vítimas têm filho levava gostam
verdadeiramente por cento
olham pro futuro e veio ao seu par certo
e mesmo assim não conseguiram deixar de
3 é tão clara que a pergunta mais
interessantes é porque trazem os casais
felizes e respostas ganhar mais em
atenas no fundo no fundo eles querem
mesmo deixar o parceiro no fundo fundo
ou mesmo à procura de outra pessoa mas
então chega a ciência e vamos confundir
outra vez com os seus estudos e alguns
estudos que mostram que apenas 10% dos
casos equipe pessoa que trai fica com a
pessoa
o terceiro com a mãe trocou a amante em
apenas 10 por cento e que inicia uma
nova relação com aquela pessoa então se
calhar não criam mesmo uma nova pessoa e
eu tenho percebido que a traição é o ato
extraordinário evento individual tem
muito a ver conosco e tem menos a ver do
que pensávamos com as características do
nosso processo com os fãs da relação é
mesmo algo extraordinariamente
individual e esta pode ser uma segunda
verdade desconfortável é quando eu traio
eu não quero o mesmo deixar o meu
parceiro não quer mesmo deixar esta
relação
o que eu quero fugir a sete pés da
pessoa contornei nessa razão então por
que nós mesmos
a festa que estava datam de capa treino
e parceria entre 30 c e vida é e mesmo
assim nós vimos esta verdade porque os
custos de uma atração do planeta casal
se sobreviver são elevados
quem trai entrar fica com níveis de
culpa e oferecemos e quem é traído quem
acredite fcam pt fica sem chão por onde
caminhar quebras e imagem que tínhamos
do outro e mais do que isso quebra
sequer uma imagem tão bonita que nós
achávamos que o outro tinha de nós uma
imagem de exclusividade
eram exclusivos serão os únicos depois
da traição da nossa única
alguém foi mais um único que eu
esse é o meu habitat profissional e
acredita que ela tenha bons resultados
os estudos indicam que temos melhorias
entre 60 a 90 por cento dos casos nada
mal mas não é para meninos
os pesados quando chega o fim
completamente sem papel tudo arde tudo
está exposto não vence querendo provar
não tem essa capacidade de vencer tudo
mudar a tradição de sítio de um centro
do sul da dor e da gostei quando teve a
vida do casal para um ponto mais lá
atrás da trajetória um ponto do futuro é
claro mas um ponto a construção da
confissão da renovação de um novo
contrato emocional encontrar porque quer
mais mas eu tentei com mais propriedade
mas também mais desafia
afinal por que teremos este aqui que
estão escrevendo uma resposta
nós queremos uma resposta tendo mesmo
falar no design temos sempre falar no
site a traição tem sempre a ver com o
desejo o desejo é estranho desejo é
muito estranho
bigu em disciplinava portas mal aparece
quando não é nada convidada quando
cremos que o aston villa ganhou por 2 e
quando nós temos a mesma mercadoria que
eu gostaria de ver visita reservada tudo
pronto temos o desejo de voltar não está
e não sabem dançar eu não vivo nem
pensava cg altamente disciplinados
advirto contraditórias exemplo exemplo
inicia uma relação de compromisso do
início da vossa relação àquela famosa
fase da paixão é aquela coisa tão
intensa que até há quem diga que durante
três meses a três anos mais do que isto
ninguém aguenta tanta intensidade nesta
fase da paixão nós não vencemos outros
netos a caminhar em direção a outro tudo
e altamente arriscado
temos que ir em qualquer momento e
teremos muitas vezes tropeçamos estamos
a dar lhes a conhecer temos tentado
tentar conhecer o outro tudo e ventura
risco transmissão inovação e tudo houve
deságio de onde está você está
completamente em altas naturalmente como
nós né prato bem altas nessa fase da
paixão e depois chegam coisas chegam
coisas boas
a relação vai avançando apaixonasse
então ostentava vai avançando vai
avançando
começamos a ter algumas rotinas alguns
rituais e só coisas boas que não gostava
de fazer com tinha havido uma série à
noite com o parceiro 45 são coisas
ótimas mas o que tem de acontecer o
design depois disso todos têm de facto a
baixar já está numa linha um caminho
mais calma que com sorte e algum engenho
de 50 e os bolsos suas vagas na minha
investigação do treinamento eu perguntar
e cerca de 400 casais o que eles achavam
casais frisa que eles achavam que
potenciava o seu site e os serão
basicamente muitas respostas nos cabem
duas caixas aventura inovação
imprevisibilidade e por outro lado
alquimia enem
que idade sentiam nus sentimos livres na
razão para estas duas caixas estas duas
características têm mais a ver com fase
da paixão e do desejo como faz caminho é
muito estável do casal
se calhar com a primeira e tem são mais
ingredientes que para além disto tem
finalidade porque a felicidade
muitas vezes ocorre com a aventura com o
risco transmissão com todas estas
enzimas que também pertenciam dias as
horas nós temos e somos treinados para
pensar que coisas caminhas como
confiança previsibilidade feminilidade
são coisas boas que fazem as relações
felizes mas podem abrir estas portas
para coisas que nós precisamos também
relação produções e podem abrir as
portas para a infertilidade
então parece temos aqui uma tempestade
perfeita tem tudo para correr mal
será que esta grande jornada tem
finalidade é precisamente este véu é
inevitável e e pode ser também ele
separava talvez não
talvez o ponto de partida para a atração
seja também o ponto de partida para a
sua prevenção
quando enfim unidades isso gera no nosso
caminho o que nós normalmente fazemos
teimosos o saltamos lá pra dentro filhos
e sete pés nunca consigamos nunca
questionamos se calhar vale a pena agora
apontar o foco para a infidelidade e
fazer algumas questões difíceis
chega de pensarmos em filme levavam
apenas dentro de um quadro de referência
moral que frank mesmo anos tem ajudado
muito
começamos a pensar em facilidade uma
forma útil de uma forma autoritária e
até de uma forma funcional para que
conservem finalidade o que foi trazido é
que câncer
a enfermidade vamos continuar discutindo
ponto de ter quando você se iniciaram
uma relação de compromisso a vossa
relação que vocês perderam que era vosso
para não perderem o outro foi dado às
vossas é que atingiram essas tendências
feitas em nome do amor romântico querido
mais um igual 1 a 1
essas tendências abriram e fecharam
esses dentes de novos mundo ou voz muito
ficou mais pequeno
essas vezes fizeram esquecer o protetor
nos 2 de crescimento
fizeram-nos amargo livre curiosa vontade
ou pelo contrário serão as condições
para uma vida previsível estavam bem
comportado
qual é que foi a última vez que darão
pro lado e virou nosso parceiro como
alguém separado como alguém único
autosuficientes com o valor não só como
uma continuação do nosso corpo
qual foi a última vez que darão pro lado
e se maravilharam com o qual
extraordinária pessoa que vocês
escolheram qual foi a última vez que em
relação a abrir um pacto e mostraram as
vossas foram levados das nossas zonas de
sombra que arriscaram dentro da relação
estas não são as perguntas mais
confortáveis do mundo mas são
necessárias for preciso eu fiquei
finalidade
mostra-nos um caminho mas não tem sido o
caminho é finalidade propões uma função
não tem de ser é solução
nós podemos pensar nem finalidade comum
um paliativo para a perda da nossa
identidade que pode ocorrer durante uma
relação estava quase como se fosse um
protesto contra a perda de outras coisas
que eram lançados até agora já não
sentimos falta pensar na infidelidade
com um lar pra nossa cidade mudança com
vai ouvir usuários senão fica tudo
primeiro temos que pensar ingredientes é
que eu vou buscar quando quando tenha
sido fora da relação e ventura e risco
em previsibilidade de autonomia
transcrição lutaram nos encontrar dentro
da relação explorando o máximo que o que
aconteceu que vocês escolheram arriscar
transgrediram dentro da relação especial
para fora cá dentro
mantendo-se em
timo e obrigado com o meu parceiro é
porque encontrar todos estes
ingredientes numa nova relação é fácil é
fácil é tradicional é convencional é um
clichê praticamente agora lutar para
encontrar esses ingredientes dentro da
relação com a pessoa que eu escolhi hoje
agora é arriscado voar algumas das
minhas vulnerabilidades perdendo esse é
transgressivo isso sim é revolucionário
isso pode permitir a infidelidade mas a
séria
agora a questão é temos coragem
[Aplausos]